the delegates endorsed the party's
election platform with a solid majority
concluding two days of debates the fdp
adopted an aggressive tone towards the
Social Democrats and the Greens
evidently ruling out any possible
coalition with them after September's
election close enough the SPD green
Menace time to put the demons haunting
Germany to get clarity progress
prosperity for all let us join that it
we shall prevail Thunder outfitting hub
yeah they're this happen the free
democrats want to reduce public sector
debt and lower taxes they're against a
nationwide minimum wage but in favor of
minimum wages in certain industries and
regions and come September they want a
repeat of the current coalition with the
Conservatives visit allemaal de for this
is the best government for Germany you
and it would be the best for the next
four years as well building on our
success for another four years here good
yeah and darshan is the party faithful
agreed delbert after a difficult patch
we've gotten into our stride we have
good leaders and good policies this
conference is proof of that I so very
motivated by brutalist speech we have a
great team and I am looking forward to
the election campaign didn't back out
food and housing I have lured us where
to have one these are optimistic words
from a party facing obliteration at the
elections unless it wins over many more
voters